alors que l'histoire d'amour entre le
réalisateur jalil lespert et laeticia
hallyday semble très passionné les
choses pourraient aller bien plus vite
que prévu entre les deux tourtereaux
devenus inséparables
car si leur histoire est plutôt jeune
les choses avancent entre les deux stars
qui n'hésite plus à s'afficher plus
amoureux que jamais au grand jour sur
les réseaux comme dans les magazines
jany laetitia semble très fusionnelle
visiblement ce n'est pas que pour
l'image car selon le magazine voici
jalil aurait demandé laetitia en mariage
c'est le 11 avril dernier sur la plage
de santa monica à los angeles que le
réalisateur aurait demandé la main de
laëtitia devant ses deux filles jade et
joy et filles à qui il a également
demandé l'autorisation d'épouser leur
mère toujours d'après le magazine folle
de joie laëtitia aurait accepté cette
demande l'information dont certains
doutent alors jalil lespert et laeticia
hallyday
un mariage impossible mais quand c'est
arrivé je l'espère au mariage impossible
alors on l'avait on avait quand même
annoncé ici en exclusivité par monsieur
kevin s'est pas trompé alors kévin
puisque voici à piquer vos infos alesi
ballon ses deux res
eh ben c'est surtout que là ils sont au
mexique en train de se la dorer
interscope break talent et non ce nom
peut pas bouger du muppet 10 km à 2 2
chez nous aimerons mexique et fiable
il est encore à c'est surtout qu'elle
signerait ce qu'avait administrative
derrière ce que faut savoir que jalil
lespert est arrivée sur le territoire
américain avec un visa de touriste
aujourd'hui ce visa tourisme expire le
20 septembre il est considéré comme
tourisme donc pour pouvoir faire
tamponner si je puis dire son visa il
faut sortir du territoire américain
adou le mexique pour ensuite se rentrer
sur le territoire pour avoir cette fois
un visa qui va expirer jusqu'au 25
juillet le temps l'ex que ce mariage
puisse organiser faute américaine
d'acheter aussi une grande maison
donc il faut web of what de poynt je
vous dis franchement je vous ai écouté
poliment mais quand on est connu pour
aller on aimait qu'on peut voir un visa
de travail très facilement ses données
c'est comme moi le visa est de plus en
plus compliqués parmi les papiers à bord
aujourd'hui ça coûte aussi énormément
d'argent
non non assuré woods avocat wissem
non c'est fait la manche demain soir moi
je suis pas conseillère conjugale mais
je lui dirai là heureusement surtout ne
fait pas ça je t'en supplie déjà non
mais moi j'y crois pas du tout couple
déjà le fait maintenant nature visa
comme par hasard pourquoi il se marie
avec elle tout de suite elle elle change
de mec tous les six mois
moi je suis désolé mais alors mariée au
premier regard j'aime pas mariée à la
première laetitia marié ou s'arrangent
domec tous les six mois
c'est pas possible un moment donné faut
réfléchir mais monsieur changer de mec
tous les jours la vie je le bol moi je
dis que c'est pas une année avant de
trouver le remède qui devrait a pas eu
10 mai je vous trouve alors je le sais
que je ne suis pas pro laetitia je vous
trouve extrêmement injuste mais on m'a
dit viens juste d'acheter bit qui a
décidé qu'il fallait attendre pendant
dix ans avant de se marier
maintenant ce n'est pas le cas mais
quand on attaque avec qui on se serait
bien que tu avec sa mariée carole et se
marier l'inspiration de benjamin mais ne
paraît pas 40 mais non mais regardez
bien il ya eu plusieurs brouillons et
aujourd'hui il a trouvé la bonne et on
remercie pour la bonne chère compilé
fiable comme la voiture c'est du 300
militants réseau mais en plus vous
coupent six mois c'est un mec avait dit
sa lune nana je suis celle de minutes ça
me choque de dire quelque chose de bien
laissez moi c'est pas bien de dire ça
maintenant et aristophane c'était moi
alors moi j'ai pas tellement d'amis moi
je vais vous dire une vérité peut-être
cru mais sincère mais on gèle il
l'espère et laeticia hallyday je m'en
bats les steaks
avec ces quinzaine d'enfants je m'en
fous d'un point de côté et des bas mais
vous inquiétez pas je connais le
producteur jay divine et la fiche par
deux on parle d'un mariage
si johnny foot merci ça veut dire qu'on
rit oui mais qui compte non pas qu'on
n'a pas demandé qui compte c'est avant
tout parce qu'ils vont se marier ce que
c'est dur à me bass a pas de rapport
avec leur wet je n'y crois pas moi mais
un droit dû endurer voiture la voiture
de son ex mari
mais c'est pire je lise à 10,6 sur ce
plateau qu'il était quand même moyen
avec sa fille si qu'il était tout le
temps là bas qui sont occupées pas faim
qui s'occupait pas beaucoup de sa fille
qui était assis au bar d'un mariage dans
marianne sens du casse et la mise bas
aux états unis et donc voilà je vais
être sincère avec vous moi j'ai eu
d'histoires d'amour quand on est
amoureux on oublie soit il et il est
arrêté d'être comme ça
vous n'êtes pas ce qu'on me dit dans
l'oreillette sur la dame je vous dis je
vous journalistes a dit moi je crois
alors c'est vrai que c'est terrible mais
quand on vit une histoire d'amour
excusez-moi banias plus inquiets après
banon et après on se rattrape et on fait
comme on peut
qu'est ce que tu fais depuis